look who it is
look at these
hello we are live good morning good
afternoon good evening wherever the hell
you are in the world and welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel with Matthew
and Harris
blue Heroes stormy bear touchdown yes
thank you
your shifts have changed so you can join
us again and we're so happy oh hang on
why not
hang on just good God see I'm out of I'm
out of touch here all right let's see
it's fine but I'll I'll run the I'll run
this starting sequence and then you can
get into it
[Music]
there we go sorry about that excellent
right so before we get too stuck in do
you want to have a little bit or do you
hear a little bit of a rumor that I've
been hearing this week should we get to
that first oh definitely interesting
foreign
news but so
um I've strung to a chap that works
um on the legal side of things over at
um MGM
and he was talking about he's the guy
that's been talking to me about it could
be a girl I say guy but it could be a
girl
try to protect his uh anonymity it could
be by gender I don't know anyway
I will pretend that nobody knows anyway
this person is the guy that's talking to
me about guy [__] sake the person
that's been talking to me about the
Warner Brothers deal and how Amazon have
been looking for a big Studio partner
now he was saying actually the Sony
apparently want big chunks of they want
to basically own parts of the IP and own
elements of anything they do with Amazon
so Amazon are not very happy about that
so they're doing projects they're okay
doing projects for Sony that are already
like existing project oh sorry brand new
projects so things like the boys they're
happy to do that
excuse me they don't want to do anything
that they already own the IP to
that means a Sony Stargate deal might be
out the car off the cards so they've
been talking with Warner Brothers now
they're doing loads of projects at work
but it's already
so we thought that was possibly very
likely and apparently they were looking
at a deal with Warner Brothers to do
um to basically rent a lot of Studio
space off them
but Warner Brothers want like a 20-year
deal
and Amazon don't want to do that because
it's just it's waiting they actually the
the long-term ambition was
to start producing things themselves and
they already do have a little bit of
Studio space actually opened towards the
end and the end of last year
um at Culver City Studios they have the
world's largest virtual Studio there
that um opened very recently so they've
already started to move along that path
of trying to get their own Studio space
so they're now pulling away from the
Warner Brothers deal as well they don't
want to do that so instead they're
looking at a partnership with
um a private Studio firm that currently
owns call the studio where Amazon's got
its World Headquarters is it called the
studio and they actually leased the
buildings off this company
um and I'll get the name of the company
actually while we're chatting because I
wrote it down
um
uh they've just bought Vancouver film
studios they've got a partnership with
Bridge Studios where Stargate was first
filmed it's called the Hackman group
an MBS
so in the moment Amazon are looking to
having a bit of a more
um long-term partnership with those guys
instead and they're actually the world's
largest private owner of Studio space
so not a bad partnership to have from
like I said they've already got a work
in partnership with them because at
least buildings off them already so
it's a bit of a different direction
basically because of money it looks like
Amazon are trying to bring their
Ambitions forward a bit it looked like
they were trying to do these Warner
Brothers deals so that they could get
stuff going quicker
but it's not really looking like it's
working out so they're going to bring
those plans forward and maybe do this
stuff themselves which I don't know what
you guys think but I'm thinking that's a
that's a good thing I think that's a
great thing honestly they need to start
doing things themselves and that that
just puts a drive under the company as a
whole not just for our little pocket
fandom of Stargate but
if it drives a company forward as a
whole and it happens to be Stargate that
does that that means they're that much
more invested in just the IP and it's
fans and the fan base which means
we get to be happy campers all the time
which I I like to be you know so you
don't have to share any of the proceeds
with other production companies either
well also I think there's this I mean
one of the comments we get quite a lot
is too many cooks spoil the broth
and any company that's going to be
involved we want to put a Sony anybody
they're going to they're going to want
to have some influence on
90 seconds
what was that I don't know but it was
funny
what was that okay so for some reason I
can't interact with the chat and I was
just trying to
I can't type in the chat
ignore me you can just speak
you you have a forum you can talk
well I know but I just want to say
everyone's saying oh hey stormy how's it
doing so weirdo you know you know it's
just but I can't say hey back so anyway
I can't interact in the chat so
everybody in the chat I hey how are you
missed you bunches
drugs
okay
good good all right well so what what
what's your opinion on this this idea
then actually Amazon might store along
go with Stargate and other projects like
RoboCop well I mean it's my initial fear
is it's going to end up like you know uh
fractured like Spider-Man you know SUNY
and Marvel Marvel and Sony you know
everybody owning a little bit of this
and a little bit of that and um
keep them away from the chat damn it
yeah yeah thank you very much so yeah
but that would be my main concern and
it's I think
you know it's we've seen it be
problematic in other circles you know in
other franchises and
um it seems like there's so many
challenges as it is for Stargate and I'd
hate to see
you know
Studio territorial fighting over it and
every time that happens I think the fans
lose
yeah 100 yeah no I agree
ment
you basically touched on it
less people means spent spending less
money to pay them
which means they can reinvest that
potentially back into it and actually
have more of a budget
because they're not they're not having
to you know pay
Warner Brothers uh 20 fear or attempts
at fee or whatever it is or turn your 10
feet 20 fee that money can go directly
into production costs I mean they're
probably gonna
be paying this Hackman group a little
bit but
if they're already doing that anyway
maybe that's already allocated yeah well
it's renting space I mean yeah
regardless of how you they do do this
there are production costs there are
costs that go involve these things
um but it seems to be I mean this this
company this um this group that have
been they've been buying
they've only really existed in the
studio Market business for about 15
years and now they're the excuse me
they're the largest single owner of
Studio space
um The Bridge Studio where sg1 was
originally filmed near Vancouver
um is is going through a massive
um rebuild at the moment they're
building 60 sound stages there and it's
in partnership with this company this
hackerman group
um and MBS which are the um world's
largest
um single owner if they own the world's
largest prop
um house they are the world's largest
supplier of like lighting and grip
equipment and stuff they're a big
company and but this Hackman group like
I said they weren't really in the
business 15 years ago now they are
studios in seven different countries in
60 different locations
60 sound stages that's a lot of sound
stages that's a lot of sound stages even
though Hollywood's terms man that's a
lot of sounds
like they're building like big sound
stages to like make movies and stuff but
then there's going to be smaller ones
because it talked about podcasts and
things as well so I think some of those
sound stages might literally be our room
with like sound proofing so I think 60
might sound more impressive than it
actually is but it was a big site
already but that president is still
investment isn't it into content
creation
it's investment it's good it's a couple
of billion quid it's been it's a big
project
um over the next two to three years and
but there's a massive shortage of Studio
space so they're just investing
investing but they these guys have also
just bought the other like that other
Studio space in Vancouver had opened up
an interesting possibility to me though
could Stargate go home
yeah I'm really hoping so
yeah it would just come full circle it'd
be great for it to go back to Vancouver
I mean it
even if
I don't know I mean I I ultimately I
don't really care where it's filmed but
like
that's where it came from maybe we'll
get to see those forests again
that's what I'm excited for Aries Spock
in the forests Harry should be happy
about that
yes yep
um Steve Jones has got a great comment
thank you I'm really glad you typed that
out yeah thanks for stopping by
if you want to or don't somebody of
importance I'm not important
I thought we were important you're
important
hang on am I am I saying that right
impotent input
no somebody's interested
somebody did not have their Lucky Charms
this morning that's all yeah anyway back
to something that is important actually
talking about a TV show we like and
enjoy talking about and if you don't
want to talk about it go away
there's a hack actually if you don't
know what we're saying you can press alt
and f4 on your keyboard it just it mutes
us and deletes our Channel forever
do that
I like that easy comments okay comments
going oh God I hate your channel
I mean if we want to add some validity
to ourselves we don't legitimately have
a rocket scientist back with us now so
like build spaceship so you know
hey
yeah yeah anyway anyway we don't have to
stress
um yeah um I I just made the point
wasn't part they did have to agree to
produce a a big percentage of stuff in
America
just stop
um because there was this woman God
who's basically the head of the
um uh the the body that had to go
through which I've now forgot the name
of
anyway
she's attacking she's going after Amazon
again at the moment she's threatening to
sue Amazon for someone else something
else they did and the financial
regulatory body whatever it's called
um
so they basically have these backdoor
deal to sort of say well we'll produce
but it's not everything they just have
to produce so much percentage of new
material so it doesn't mean it can't be
Canada and it just means that there'll
be other stuff in America and big
Productions in America as well so tax
tax dollars tax centers
um
one of the things we did talk about this
week and a couple of videos I did I
talked about
directors that actually they've been
talking to directors because we think
we're getting and moving
I've heard a couple of other things
recently actually as well but everywhere
it might be movie TV series movie TV
series but I'll talk about that later
the names that we got Jordan peel
who did nope recently who um did the
twilight zone is a writer on that he did
a screenplay first Candyman he did that
that horror movie us which was
terrifying
such a clever movie
um well first of all what what would you
think about him because when I heard
that name I was like what
but
well
one thing it just did you say Jordan
Peele yeah
from Key and peel yeah
he did that yeah that's where I know him
from oh yeah he was an actor for years
yeah you know his face hmm
well a lot of times you know when we
hear these you know
um announcements of directors and for
this
film or TV show that there's a lot of
fandom about we just can't wrap our head
around it
a lot of times those are really
successful you know uh Lord of the Rings
uh Battlestar Galactica the reboot for
that you know and we you know the the
people pushing those like what how you
know
Peter Jackson really how it's just the
frighten how is he ever going and it was
gorgeous you know
the reboot was still probably some of
the best sci-fi I ever filmed
yeah it was at the start a lot of times
you know when we hear this
this you know of a director's mention
for something that's beloved like
Stargate and
um it actually turns out better than
anyone ever expected you know so
uh I'm always willing to give these guys
a a uh unless they're straight out of
film school then that's an issue but you
know it's a lot of times they really
they really can't step up and bring
something unique to the screen that we
really haven't seen before
yeah well Harris you watched
um no I've seen every single one of his
films I think I've seen everything he's
done including produced besides Twilight
Zone the new stuff so I there's a couple
different comments in here that I agree
with wholeheartedly and they all kind of
Go in different directions
Jordan peel needs to just keep on his
keep I can't read needs to just keep on
doing his own movies in his own way Don
Juan said he does amazing work both of
those are very true and there was one
more Paul Maloney said with horror
directors they can keep to a budget so
all those are very true about Jordan
peel uh budgets are very
like that big and it's funny but it's
important nowadays
Indiana Jones is going to lose a bunch
of money most likely from the West
because of budget it's just it's only
what 25 million
which is a little less than the flash
right I think which is bad oh that cut
flash get 55 at the end of the day okay
so yeah secular monk also makes a good
point after that my thought process is
Jordan peel is an amazing filmmaker he
knows the ins and outs of the entire
industry he's a great producer and actor
obviously key and peel he got that down
pat over time and he knows human
psychology through comedy which is one
of the easiest ways to really get into
someone's brain so he knows how to write
something he knows how to make something
good he's an excellent filmmaker I I
really enjoyed all three of his films us
I think is his weakest by far uh nope is
a really cool sci-fi horror movie that
changes what it does in a few different
ways I know some people didn't like it a
whole bunch but I think a lot of the
things he put into that could fit very
well into Stargate even uh get out get
out is just psychological as hell and it
just it makes you think he's amazing at
what he does
but I know not everybody's loved the
Twilight Zone and the Candyman remake
was good
but not great and he wrote both of those
and and as of now he's only directed the
things that he has written and come up
with himself every time he's done an IP
of sorts he produces and gets somebody
else to direct it kind of does that so
that's my worry with Jordan peel but if
because because there's already we look
we've talked about 100 times there's
already a script out there
one way or another and whether it's a
full script it's a script that would be
reworked by another director or what
there is at least part of a script and
there's a Bible that has to be followed
to a degree and and layers and layers
and layers of things and I don't know if
Jordan Peele wants
to deal with that I I think he'd want to
do more of his own thing and I don't
know if because his
he'd be great in the fact that he's a
really good character study he he is
really really good about getting like
two three four five characters that he
wants you to know about
good screen time good good character
arcs good development through that
with adding the minimum of four
characters for an sg1 plus all these
Legacy characters I think that might be
too much for him and not not in like a
bad way like he couldn't do it but not
in the way that he would want to do it
I'm speaking for him right now so that
could be completely wrong uh but but
it would have been written
kind of thing so he's not actually doing
that much work there I mean it seems to
me that this is almost like they've
spoken to two or three different
directors they've both spoken to more
than that these are just the ones that
the person I spoke to knows about
um but they're going to be going to them
going like look we've got we're going to
do the Stargate movie This is the sort
of this is what we've already got in
development
what would you do with it and then
Jordan Peel's gonna put his spin on it
apparently according to a friend of the
channel Jordan peel is a big fan of MGM
and he's a bit of a buff on it and
um there is another connection to Target
that I've I promised I wouldn't mention
um but this this this may this name made
no sense to me on the surface when I saw
it thinking about the movies he's done
well if you think about it he's got a
he's got a history of working in comedy
he's got a long history working in
sci-fi and Twilight Zone and all this
other thing but also I mean the one
thing about nope was that it was it was
grounded in a an element of reality
I mean for me those are the three most
important things of Stargate that it's
Gotta Have
yeah
I think that you could level up the
humor quite a bit and um
in Stargate if you did get it because
his stuff is is hilarious I don't know
if you've ever seen big mouth
but that's hilarious it's a cartoon but
it's what it's like it's a very funny
adult cartoon
yeah
and then obviously key and peel is just
funny anyway
his comedy and could be actually quite
quite interesting because it's not it's
not always like stupid comedy sometimes
it's quite clever comedy
like it has substance and like you think
about stuff well after you've watched it
yeah
and and I just think it's it's like I
say it's one of those names on the
surface doesn't make any sense at all
but when you dig into it and start
really thinking about it
it's like all of a sudden it's like ah
he's an open coming director he's got
he'll bring fresh blood into it and he's
got a history that might work but
yeah and and he could bring the Sci-Fi
as he proved in nope uh he could bring
the horror aspect of things that is just
the terrifying vast Galaxy of of space
or the you know the expansion of space
whatever uh and and he's funny he can
bring some good comedy back to it which
as I might be wearing an SGU shirt right
now but we could use a little comedy you
know
we talked about this Target Universe was
the funniest one
Eli had some damn good comments I'll
tell you that but that's about it
Eli Eli was my you know Eli was my
favorite character from SGU I mean it
was just the best line I'm not math boy
you know he he had her I thought he had
a really good delivery you know little
do we all know stormy is just Eli
Wallace 70 years or 54 years and then
back in time a little bit I've been
through the gate and back
when he returned circuitry just said Eli
wasn't funny I completely disagree but
Adam Brody was also hilarious Adam Brody
was very funny
emo what's funny he just wasn't haha
funny
Simpsons quote he was funny he just
wasn't laugh out loud funny but no the
whole show wasn't funny to me in this
book anyway the the next name on the
list that we've got the name is Chris
McKay who recently did the tomorrow war
and he's just done Renfield which I'm so
desperate to watch oh my God all right
Renfield Jesus why did you even say that
now I'm all lusting for it again Damon
oh God damn I want to watch that film
lower your expectations
I was ecstatic to go see it I had that
same thing and it's not bad it's not bad
at all it's actually very enjoyable but
it's just it's not it's it's not as good
as you can come building myself up it's
not what you want yeah well the only
other thing this guy's done right he did
The Dungeons and Dragons honor among
Thieves which I saw a thing recently
it's slating it and I'm like I watched
that film I really enjoyed it
up it was a great movie I thought it was
brilliant the only problem with this it
is like the definition of simple like it
is just like all right cookie cut cookie
cut cookie cut cookie cut here but it is
very well cookie cut together uh it's
placed together very well puzzle pieces
very well together but I I loved it
it didn't do great at the cinema but
nothing is doing well at the cinema at
the moment literally everything is
losing money except for Maverick which
we're gonna talk in a minute and Avatar
everything else is losing money it seems
at the moment yeah and uh yeah it did be
great and the only other thing this
guy's doing is like he's done a bunch of
cartoon stuff he did like um
and Lego Batman
um so probably his best film honestly
which is I did but do a little
uh Robert Downey Jr
yeah sorry get Chris McKay out of here
if he was part of that yeah
looking at his like credits
there are a lot of
kid Centric like properties here
yeah
is he the kind of guy to make something
a little bit more serious like Stargate
the tomorrow Warren Renfield
they're they're much more adult humor
oriented not humor oriented Renfield
wise adult oriented tomorrow War wise at
least I think the only reason his name
is on this list if I'm honest is because
he did the tomorrow war with Amazon and
somebody went
we're doing Stargate how about that guy
that did tomorrow well we did a good job
with that is that that one where they
all come back from the future to bring
people from now into the future so they
can fight all right Chris Pratt that's
it
which it was not that great of a movie
it was it was really fun uh but in it it
wasn't like the direction or the story
or or even the characters that you
enjoyed it's just the bombast of the
action and the really cool they had
really great CGI monsters in that movie
it was great
love love
those really funny places and bits and I
I thought it worked I thought it it it
started badly and got better
yeah yeah the first third I mean Andrew
just did this crap I thought the first
third probably was crap
the fight the middle bit was fine but
the final third that I thought was
actually really good except for the
daughter stuff I thought that was kind
of
yeah but I thought it ended strong
which was maybe I wish it had started as
strong too honest it would have been a
better film but it was okay
um I don't think it quite knew what it
was
early on it was trying to be maybe a bit
serious and then it was trying to have a
bit of funny and I didn't quite know
what it was but anyway which would be
very worrisome with new Stargate because
like we talked about Jordan peel being
able to balance horror comedy and sci-fi
well
it wasn't well balanced in tomorrow war
and with all of those things being
exasperated the way to the way they are
within Stargate that that would be a
difficult task to put on somebody's
hands that didn't necessarily achieve
that the first time around
yeah yeah and um yeah if he didn't quite
get to grips of what the project was
then that is a concern isn't it the
director he's supposed to be your your
guiding star that North Star
yeah yeah anyway so the last name before
we move on to other stuff was Joseph
kazinski now why would they have spoken
to Joseph kazinski it makes no sense at
all just to piss you off
with me
[Music]
one of the biggest hits in the world
well definitely since covered so yeah
I'm remotely surprised we spoke to this
guy and he's got it the way you said
that makes it as if the last thing it
was covered
that was popular it was a popular moment
why don't my elbow
immediately sorry Harris
I was just joking I said you're
developing tinnitus on stream yeah
it's um possibility
um
oh it's the it's a black plague it's the
black death but it's gonna start
dropping off me
oh the next next fun thing to happen in
the 20s but anyway so he also did
Oblivion he also did
um Tron legacy
did you say Trump Legacy
the blue one
well that makes much more sense because
God knows what I just can't handle on
more Trump Legacy Jesus Christ four more
years four more years
and I thought Oblivion was was all right
I think he's a strong director I just
think he would have to work with
somebody that understands Stargate if
he's going to do that but
do you do you guys at least understand
[Music]
why these people have been spoken to I
mean
I understand kalinsky
how you say it Kozinski yep yeah I
understand that one fully the
Chris McKay Maybe
that makes sense because the Amazon
connection yeah yeah the
um
whatever his name peel
from Camp Hill Jordan Peele Jordan peel
I don't know is it just because it's
funny or have you seen his movies though
I've seen
a few because there's movies or anything
but funny typically okay I've not seen
any of the series there's no humor nope
oh we've got all three very serious yeah
yeah I'll be completely honest I only
found out his first name at the
beginning of this stream I didn't know
Jordan peel was him I knew him as peel
because of Key and Peele
yeah yeah for his movies think
everything he's done prior to that
comedy and then just turn that
completely on its head and make it scary
or not even necessarily scary more scary
in the sense of like psychological
Thriller like just with your brain nope
is the one you told me to watch isn't it
yep
I haven't watched it
check it out I will I will before he
gets the movie of course maybe not into
the long list of movies that Matt hasn't
seen
um no but let's just talk about the
films I have seen and we'll get there a
lot quicker we're working on your movie
education don't you worry
um but but yeah I mean all of these
names to be honest thing and I'm
absolutely certain there are going to be
more people I've spoken to we just don't
know who they are these are just the
three that like say my source is aware
of and these these conversations go back
at least six months as well
um apparently Joseph gazinski was spoken
to in November
two or three times I'm not sure about
Jordan peel but yeah a lot of the
conversations go back away
but um well that makes sense because I
think by the time we get to the point of
announcement they're going to want to
director on board
so yeah
and I have a few ideas on which
direction to go so if we do get an
announcement in like two weeks
and which doesn't feel possible at the
moment right at the moment I just think
how no chance
um I know they're still waiting on stuff
that happens with the directors and
everything else but
um they've got to have they've got to
drag out a directive they've got to have
they've got to aren't they
I mean it's their guiding Stars their
directors their North Star whether the
writers have spent two years making this
happen or whatever
the directors they're North Star and
it's the face of the of the film until
you get one big name actor and if you
don't get a big name actor it's still
the he's he or she whoever's directing
is the face of that so they they
definitely need to
it's the captain basically and it's I
mean
um even if somebody else is still doing
all the development which we think
obviously Mark Ferguson hopefully still
be involved the director really decides
the direction
the tone
so everyone else comes from there so you
know it's definitely
um their film you know they have to
deliver the the edit to the producers to
uh
to distribute I mean it's you know yeah
there's lots that goes into it but you
know it's the kind of their
responsibility to deliver the final
product
I think it's when there's a good
director and the director does have that
control is when you get a good product
I think
it's when you when the director doesn't
have that control and when things that
that's when I think things go sideways
don't they basically yeah
yeah so let's hope they get this
decision right
ah anyway we'll move on to another
subject so talking about a movie at all
is it what the fans want so before I
tell you about the poll I did a couple
of days ago there's no add one and a
half thousand votes
what do you guys
I know we've discussed this once or
twice before but what do you guys want
do you even want a movie honestly I'd
rather have a series I get more you know
I get more story with the series than 90
minute movie
yeah
um
but
yeah at this point I'd be happy with
anything
I just want Stargate to come back
I I say that I don't I'm not gonna be
happy with anything I don't want a web
series
like a little mini series kind of thing
I don't want I want something big
so either a movie or a series
20 Seasons yeah yeah just keep it going
forever yeah yeah immediately like
commissioned 20 Seasons man exactly
right go for it yeah 200 hours of
Television bare minimum thank you
that'll do it I'll be happy yeah sure
and they can do the episode 200 again
oh yes I like that thinking I like that
thing with puppets excellent good good
so I actually would love it yeah I would
to be honest that 200th episode I think
I'm in the minority possibly I hated it
I kind of I I respected what they were
doing
[Music]
okay now now we begin the next five
minutes of pettiness
[Laughter]
I know we've all become he's got too big
for his [__] boots here boy
look how Brave he's getting
um he's gonna be like bloody Sarah under
the big slap on the phone looking
forward from me anyway
um I I respected what they were doing I
just thought it was and I respected it
was the 200th episode and they just let
him go crazy with it
it's just I I loved it the first time I
watched it but then I've watched it
since and I'm sort of like oh my God
it's not an episode you'd re-watch if
that makes sense it's like first episode
you know I loved it for what they were
doing but
um but anyway
what the fans want so I asked everybody
on the Community page I asked people
recently what they didn't want
um but then that's the real question
what do you actually want from a
Stargate franchise because I know this
is something that recently was asked for
a marketing department part of the pr
marketing team to come up with an answer
for the development a series with sg1
SGA SGU actors in a new series with a
new cast
a movie with returning cast members and
a movie with new cast maybe a cameo or
two here right and that's we've had 1500
votes
what do you think was the most popular
vote on their the most the old actors
yeah what do you think the percentage of
the vote was
at first I'm going to say like 80 90 I
was gonna say 80.
at least three quarters
63 oh wow
well because a new series with a new
cast may be a cameos or two got 28 of
the vote so that was still a really
popular vote a movie
either way four percent with returning I
mean a movie with returning cast members
only got four percent of the vote that
was the least popular option
uh yeah even
you know even if it's an I would rather
have a new series news stories new
characters with maybe you know some you
know some cameos peppered here and there
President Carter would be a really cool
thing but you know just uh just a
one-off movie 90 minutes I mean that's a
lot of effort for at least very little
payback for the fans and it means me
yeah a lot of money a lot of risk yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and realistically they go if
they're going to do a series anyway
they're going to have to bring in new
people
yeah uh so that first option is a pipe
dream anyway
oh you know start the start the series
again and just bring the old people back
that's never going to happen because the
SG-1 they're all old like a lot of them
are older some most some of them are
dead
yeah
SGA
to an extent same sort of thing they're
older SG is probably the only realistic
one you could actually do bring back all
of the cast just in terms of people who
are alive and young enough to do it
things like that
um
so yeah I mean I I am with everyone who
voted for that I would love that
10 years ago
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but obviously
in a situation we're in it's going to be
it's gonna have to be new cut new cars
but
we'd like to see cameos of the at least
the the big four from SG-1 and then
maybe some from SG and SGU
think some of the sg1 characters could
return I mean Ben Browder could return
Michael Shanks could return a man's
tapping could return
I think 90 of sg1 could return in 98 of
SGA could return an 100 of SGU could
return
albeit the deaths and stuff honestly I
think there's room for all of them and
those are the stories even though I I do
agree we don't want to see the Neutered
versions of our old favorite characters
I don't think
if if you put all those characters into
it I don't think you can neuter them and
if you do it would just be an injustice
to just both the fans and the characters
themselves I guess I'm thinking Mark
Fergus is on the mind because the
expanses Game of Thrones for sci-fi and
in my mind uh in a lot of ways where
first four seasons were amazing the last
two little Game of Thrones first six
seasons amazing last two seasons a
little iffy that happened with some
production changes and stuff but both
those series
truly cover a multitude of characters
and do it very very well Mark Fergus is
one of the people that does that uh and
if you hire I I don't necessarily say
I'm not thinking that we should go like
Game of Thrones route and make it super
serious and then House of dragon route
super serious and all these different
things but there is a way to balance all
that it's difficult and you have to hire
the right people but there is a way to
balance all that and it would be nice
for them to do that because that means
they that means Amazon would especially
if they're the ones making it at the end
of the day and it's not outsourced
elsewhere
they have that much more vested interest
not just in in the actual film or TV
series both maybe but all in us and and
the fans as well that would be one of
those things we discussed it a long time
ago
if Amazon is the one that ends up making
it
they and it's not a movie it's a TV
series they really need to push it out
there if it's a movie as well they
really need to push it out there put
that stuff on your Amazon Prime boxes
everywhere that's the best way to get
eyes on it and I think
if they were to do all that that'd be
the best way to both get funding
continuous funding and open more eyes
just on on whatever it is initially
because the one good thing about a movie
because the more we talk about it the
more it sounds good to me in a lot of
ways this conversation is kind of
made my brain go a little wild though uh
uh a movie's good for eyes it's better
for eyes no matter how many people you
want to go watch it on Amazon Prime
think about I think realistically how
many people go watch Amazon Prime for TV
shows week by week the boys is like the
only show I can think about that there
are even big things like billions and uh
what's Phoebe Waller Bridges show
fleabag and stuff like that but that's
not like you don't get the numbers there
every week so that's my biggest thing
where a movie could put it in its grave
just as fast as it
could help it rise the eyes will be on a
movie the the 24-hour news sources will
be on a movie more so
um well that when I was chatting to this
person that could be a girl
um about the um movie
and they actually said look it's the
only thing that's definite is that the
movie is in development
that that he was in that that's definite
that is happening and I said well does
that mean we're only getting a movie and
he was just like well no
so I was like well
she says well they've always said they
were going to develop the plan was to
have the movie in the TV series in
development sort of at the same time and
they've been developing both he says the
the script that is produced for a
um
that that Mark Fergus has written he
says that that is being asked they've
asked to see if that can be moved into
the movie script that was that's true
because but that still doesn't mean this
TV a movie is going to come first we
could get a TV series first down
it's because it takes so much longer to
do the movie
so we know the movies come in
but the idea was to sort of do these
things at the same time and to film them
at the same time and if they do that
there's no reason why we couldn't get it
so
what decision do you think's been made
on that one and his answer was I don't
think they have
I don't think there is a decision I
don't think they've made I don't think
they've actually got that far
well and that just blows my freaking
mind to be honest I mean well my
question is does Amazon even have the
money to do all that
they've got two billion dollars a year
budget for Prime for for Amazon and so
you know they're that's you know rings
of power is half of that this year
you know I mean so I mean that's a
I mean something as expansive as
Stargate
you know with all the locations and
different sets and the aliens and
spaceships and all the CGI I mean that
it starts to add up after a while maybe
they're looking at the issue let's just
do a movie see how it goes because
that'll be a lot cheaper than you know
committing to three seasons
and they've already at the end of the
day
got them put them onto one side four
cinematic movies we think that's why
they've decided to do a cinematic movie
because the money's already there
they've already budgeted for it well
they were okay budgeted to do five or
six cinematic movies a year and it seems
they've done that without actually
deciding what movies they were going to
do
let's just do a Stargate movie we've got
we've got we've got the money there
let's just do that
um but
it's it seems to me that there's
there's an appetite for it and and
Amazon desperately do want to do this
yeah
um but it's going to be through MGM it's
it's mgm's budget it's MGM they're going
to be
behind it
and so Amazon's just a distributor
in terms of the
it's confusing because MGM has been
absorbed into Amazon
animals and pictures to a degree and but
there are still people
that run sort of like MGM plus Michael
Wright is still there and he's the he's
the biggest voice he wants a TV series
but he wants it for MGM Plus
and I think that will be a massively
unpopular decision
yeah
I was just going to say you know going
back to um why do we go to Amazon Prime
to watch
man
when I get like I will go to um like
apple plus or Disney Plus or whatever
just look at see what they got you know
see what's new and see what's going on I
never do that with Amazon Prime you know
is you know I'll hear something from
like you guys okay it's on Amazon Prime
so I'll go look for it
you know if
um
the only reason I watched so much Amazon
Prime last year was because it brings
the power
and as soon as it was over it really
didn't go back unless I wanted to watch
rings of power again
um so they do so so anyway somebody in
the chat was saying yeah that that's
kind of what they're trying to do is
just get more people they're trying to
fix the problem of no one goes to Amazon
Prime
to watch new stuff it's just not you
know maybe this would help that
mechanism so I honestly think the
biggest problem Amazon Prime's got is
it's not very easy to negotiate the
website is Netflix you know you go on
and whatever you see you can watch with
Amazon Prime it's like can I actually
watch that
well I'm not gonna have to pay 20 pounds
to watch it
or am I gonna have to subscribe to this
watch it so yeah what you see on the
menu I watched batch of the future last
week or the week before on the way home
from work on Amazon Prime
if I go on it now continue watching rent
or buy
um
yeah it's like if it's to rent or buy
don't pull it on Prime video pull it
somewhere else yeah and that was the
biggest problem with prime but Prime
don't like we've said this for long term
Prime don't want to be a channel they
want to be an aggregator of other
channels that's their long-term goal
they they want it to be the place you go
to look for everything but not
necessarily
to watch that you will think they want
MGM plus to be an add-on
that you go and watch I'm looking at the
MGM plus the thing right now look at the
most popular show
isn't it right look at the popular two
star SGA was right after Teen Wolf was
three
more
Um well hey and SG is number four hey
and then the Pink Panther show and we'll
start at the movies down there huh and
then RoboCop the two things that they're
on about actually bringing back first
Robocop and starting yeah the two main
things they want to bring back from MGM
you can't forget legally blunt three we
keep forgetting each other
I mean it's the most important thing for
me
um
where that girl is and what's she doing
there surely she's president if I know
the last thing I went to go purposely
watch on Amazon Prime was
um there was another episode of uh uh
The Grand Tour
with the you know
yeah and then I was like oh back to
Disney Plus
or Yellowstone or whatever the hell it
was
you know um yeah they do have to yeah
they're they're um
they need a better interface because I
can never find
anything that really is worth watching
unless this I have to hear it from
someplace else and then I go hunt it
down watch it and then leave which I
know is not what they want I think
there's actually too much on there
because they advertise stuff that's on
Netflix and things because they want you
to walk through Prime it's just too much
um and you can't so you can't find stuff
I think the bigger the biggest problem
with prime is like you said you you
click something thinking you can watch
it and you can't you have to subscribe
or you have to buy it or you have to
write it
that's not a good user experience like
we've never turn off you go to Netflix
and you know you can watch it you don't
have to pay anything extra you're
already paying for your subscription so
you go there you see a movie yeah I'll
watch that and their their Discovery
system is quite good as well on Netflix
where it just shows you what's trending
in your country
um what's popular in your area kind of
thing so you can discover new things
that way with
Prime
um I mean I'm looking at it now it's
continue watching so it sings I've
already I've already seen
uh trending movies all of which you have
to buy
and then
not a lot of anything I'm really
interested to be fair there is a free
with Prime
option down there that you can find just
movies that are free with prime
original author always free and so that
there is you can find it it's just that
you need to know what you're looking for
and it's not for laughing quality I
think everything Amazon Prime has made
have like Prime Originals whether it be
TV shows or movies have all been pretty
damn good and all maybe not well
received in like a a successful type of
way but well received and a Critic an
audience vote of confidence kind of way
I mean I I don't know why they don't
promote that over obviously they want
more money which is why hey go watch
this through us but I'll be back here
one second guys keep joking I'll be back
in a sec yeah and it just kind of feels
like Amazon and instead of book service
and hey buy this buy this buy this it's
now they're really putting Amazon Prime
into the the film aspect of their stuff
which I don't blame them but put it down
further on the list or put it all in one
one like little section of right okay
they could have a section just for
services
like literally just a button that does
not services and then you connect your
accounts to that or you subscribe
through that and then everything from
the services tab then gets Amalgamated
into your content delivery or your
content Discovery that's kind of the way
Apple TV is you know if you go that if
you use the Apple TV app
you know there's like TV shows there's
movies and you get into that and that's
stuff you can buy yeah yeah you know
apple plus then you see you know Silo
and foundation and all the shows hey
you're not having to go buy and do a
transaction for you just watch it you
know and you can also like I think I get
a AMC through Apple TV and it just kind
of Blends right in you know Apple TV and
Hulu both do what Amazon Prime's trying
to do in infinitely better ways oh God
yeah
it's a really great the only thing I run
into every once in a while with that is
like uh subscribing to Showtime I'll get
like oh this is and that's the only and
that's rare you know
I just went ahead and subscribed so I
didn't have to deal with that anymore
yeah 100
right so I did a video on I think I put
it out on Friday
um pretending to be it's it's health and
safety guys brother piago
and these um in the British office of
the PR Company and they're trying to
figure out how to release the um
big news that the Stargate program
to the to the general public releasing
to the general public
um go and watch it it took me forever to
edit
um so yeah literally well Matt had to go
couldn't figure it out and I had to
either go and I couldn't figure it out
and in the end I figured it out but oh
man
um uh so yeah it was a lot of fun doing
but my God it took ages so
um and if you think that your name
appeared in that thing because it it it
did so one a few of the actual um me and
Jay sat there on a call for like three
two three hours or whatever it was on
Sunday
well was it only an hour it felt yeah
Sunday evening
would not figure out how to do it anyway
we're like yeah we should put our
subscriber's name in there we should put
uh David B uh Kerry Shelley I think
Harris was in there and then you put me
in there and every everyone's telling me
to shut Up
appeared to me so I I just it amused me
there and then I like it when you
actually caught with a good idea anyway
shut up oh no that's actually quite a
good idea anyway
um but it's just it was I I'm now gonna
have to follow up with a serious
question because we fear all the
comments a couple of people didn't quite
get that it was a joke
and um actually then put some very very
long very serious answers to what was
supposed to just be a bit of a giggle
but I have to wonder
you know
how do they release how if we think
they're gonna make the Stargate an Open
Secret at the end no no you know the
re-release to the public
how do they do that if it's going to be
a movie first
oh
because you've got two hours
that's not a lot of time to tell a story
the only realistic way I could see it in
a movie setting is be like Independence
Day style like the aliens just arrived
and then they have to like and then
everyone knows aliens exist and then
they go right we've got this government
like Secret Agency we're at it for like
20 30 years don't worry about it let's
destroy the aliens and then they can
deal with the aftermath later on
or yeah I mean they could always do you
know
aliens beaming down and you know
Times Square Piccadilly Circus or
something like that and just like oh
well now we got like like Matt said well
we got to deal with these guys and then
we'll tell them about this Star Gate
thing later
you know we've been fighting this huge
Interstellar Intergalactic War
or extra Galactic actually and yeah they
finally got here and there were some
skirmishes here and then you know your
lives have been at risk for the last 30
40 years no but it's okay
[Music]
but you know and then the other thing is
what would people even care I mean let's
go back to the whole reality
um UFO thing I mean what a couple years
ago this is how Jamie and I met
you know the New York Times posted you
know this story where the government the
the uh office of uh Office of the
uh what was the OSI the Navy is always
the office of uh the dod as well special
anyway yeah the dod was initially saying
well we are in you know we are in
possession of ships not of this Earth
it's like there's no follow-up story
it was a press conference a few weeks
ago some dude from
some some
um some
military thing literally done the press
conference and and told everyone about
aliens and what they've got and blah
blah and this this and all that there
was a glory guy yeah it was all over
Tick Tock but it was not in the news
for a day for a day
at 24 7 News cycle just
turns it out and keeps your brain going
and just puts anything else out in front
of it
if the Stargate program got um
revealed then there are people who just
don't care there were people who just
deny it it even exists well the news
would move on people would forget
like
it would take something incredible like
an alien ship coming down to the planet
for people to take notice and that's the
only realistic way they can do it I mean
even if the president did a statement
basically on the podium saying that's
that'd be different
no I see if the president if if the
president right now if Joe Biden got on
a Podium now and said aliens exist
Joe Biden I didn't joke come on come on
I'm not sure he could
is he going to live long enough to get
to the podium
I saw him on an interview at the weekend
I don't want to get into politics but I
saw him in an interview
um our two or three days gone to CNN and
if I was an American I'd be a Democrat
I'm going to say that straight up I
would but I would have to vote for him
but
it was like talking to my Dottie old
Grandad and the interview was still like
oh blessed you want to wear this all the
way through she was so she was quite
patronizing to him that man is about 300
years old I think he I think it was a
weekend of Bernie's thing going on I
think he's actually dead and it's a
puppet
in power
when he spoke
people would just assume it was a
conspiracy like they're covering
something else up and this is where
they're doing it it would be oh this is
uh pulling the wall over our eyes so
they could do something else but that's
the kind of thinking people will have
because people are very untrusting
like
the government would have done
everything in in in covert times to try
and protect to protect everyone like
with lockdowns and all that and then
they they jumped immediately jump to
this is a conspiracy and that was just
little that was literally just like the
flu
now imagine they're talking about aliens
yeah
yeah I wonder if um
I'm aware covert is slightly more
serious than the flu
I had an argue with my brother-in-law
yesterday about it we won't go there
either
um we need to stay away from politics
and we need to stay away from even
though we're not thinking about doing a
side Trek opinionated episode once a
week maybe or once every couple of weeks
where we're gonna just talk about
whatever we want maybe if not the best
idea but I'll be fine
I I wonder if the movie to start with
it's been public for years
so
sorry but but stormy said something
while he was talking earlier I I I we
may have mentioned this before uh I
don't think we've really talked about it
is they could totally just finally
introduce all the technology that
they've gotten from all these other
planets all these other civilizations to
Earth and then show everybody all of our
big ass spaceships and be like guess
what we got y'all and and and that might
be like that this two cart Blanche
that's like okay it's in front of our
face We Believe now and they may never
even have to mention a Stargate Stargate
could be completely confidential to like
the world government still and they
don't have to actually have to talk
about that and they could just be like
guess what we're we're a space-bearing
civilization now surprise
they don't have to tell people how they
how they got it or how they achieved all
these things civilization we've got this
technology where we can literally
harness energy from vacuum space
so just ignore the fact we haven't given
you that for the last 20 years
um and you know we haven't cured famine
and all that which we literally have
technology for
um
ignore all of that no so if they did
that and they gave all the technology
not not gave it but showed all the
technology you want and showed
spaceships and all this stuff
that would cause Mass hysteria and mass
panic
they'd have to do it in dribs and drabs
over a course of many years for it to be
effective
because if you think about if you found
out right now that the government had
all this technology that they could have
prevented like the wars have happened in
the last 20 years
um
all the world crisis and stuff like that
and on top of that the fact that there
are
like evil aliens out there with ships
capable of coming here and destroying US
20 times over and people from other
galaxies who come trying to destroy us
and little robot spiders and all of this
stuff
you'd you people would jump off
buildings people jump off buildings
people would Riot like society would
collapse
lately
so should it be revealed then or should
it still be a secret yes I think it
should but it has to be done in a way
that makes sense
and I think
so this is obviously this is just just
my opinion but the only way it makes
sense is if there's a threat to Earth
and then
they've got no choice they can reveal
some technology but not all of it and
they can defeat that they can defeat
that threat because realistically the
Warfare most people aren't going to see
the actual Warfare side of it they're
going to see the aliens arriving
they're going to see potentially us
moving in to destroy the aliens they're
not necessarily going to see us doing it
and then they're going to see the aliens
either going home or being destroyed
the the first two things the first and
the last thing and the most important
thing in between isn't as important for
public facing
so we can literally tell them anything
at that point
we could literally say yeah we we
developed a technology just in time or
we have this technology laying around
we've been developing for a few years
and this helped this really helped us
not necessarily then having to reveal
the program
straight away but
uh wetting the whistles of everyone if
well did you get right just think about
all that
how how obviously Stargate has stayed
fairly close to like realism in in the
sense of like the things that happen on
Earth are actually happening but
how close were they like
in all actuality to following suit like
did the 2008 financial crisis happen in
the U.S while like right before SGU
happened was that happening in Stargate
Atlantis because it didn't seem to have
any effect because the budget of all
these different programs
I I think that
maybe all these wars and stuff that have
happened since Stargate would have
happened haven't happened in Stargate
world and maybe all these things have
been maybe it's been world peace for the
past 20 25 years and everyone's kind of
wondering why and and then this is
science fiction let's go speed let's
just yeah well World Peace quote unquote
there's always going to be something
they were actually ahead of us in terms
of covert they had that
yeah season 10. of course uh but yeah
I'm just thinking that it doesn't
necessarily have to follow like our
exact history it could be a
proto-history and uh and and they could
kind of play around with that and I
think I think that's what they did
anyway it wasn't I don't think
chronologically followed
current world events but obviously big
world events like the Cold War
yeah it happened because obviously that
was part of the story with like the the
Russian relationships
well there's I think uh Harris is onto
something it's like uh you could
you know you can uh definitely couch
the the script for SGU or any of the
franchises in in certain ways
where it's always going to be true like
there was a line in the in the original
Avatar movie uh this is before
um
uh Jake went to uh Pandora he was
talking about his injury you know he
said yeah you can't get you know I can't
get my uh legs fixed not on vet benefits
not in this economy well good God not in
this economy it's just that's always
been an excuse I mean for almost as long
as I've been alive I mean you know it's
not in this economy well that could have
been any time anywhere and still be true
because people always use that as a
where everybody can have everything they
want
it's um or need it's just it's never
it's never happened is it so
post scarcity economy yeah exactly like
an elder novel
hammer and sickle
hey call me back I thought you were
wakanda forevering for a second I was
like huh no I can't I can't hold my
hands into a hammering sickle so you're
just gonna get that oh I almost made a
bad joke I I okay keep going go ahead
make it elevation X yeah make a bad joke
Harris we love a bad joke well
it's not relevant to sci-fi in any way I
I've talked to you I think before that
kill Tony that comedy podcast I watched
there's this one guy who's
absolutely hilarious he's Canadian uh
and and he's his name's Aaron Belial
he's got cerebral palsy on half of his
body so his like I think it's his left
arm is a bit of a hook and it just Matt
looked like he was hooking it for a
second and it was
well as I I think we've covered Stargate
for this week but before everyone
disappears that's about to say we can't
end on cerebral palsy there's got to be
something so
um obviously we've now storm is back in
particular we normally do what have you
been watching this week thing and and
chat about you know what we think and I
don't know if you guys have seen Indiana
Jones but me and Harris have
yes so I'd love Harris I'd love to know
what you thought of Indie before we go
and then guys anything that you've seen
that you this week you wanted to talk
about would love to chat about it
because right after this I want to go
see Indy right after this year right
after so this is going to ruin this for
you oh good
so
um
I'll I'll give like my brief kind of
like non-spoilery things like I did for
the little out of theater reaction
yesterday uh it I I enjoyed it a hell of
a lot more than I expected it to but at
the same time it did not tread a single
bit of new water it didn't add anything
to
anything uh besides killing off a
certain
child I guess but that doesn't even that
doesn't happen with it's just a line of
dialogue kind of deal and that was the
only thing that I felt like it added to
the lore of Indiana Jones because even
whenever like Toby Jones is placed in
there and like that whole fun 20-minute
sequence that you get like young Indiana
Jones and and kind of sets up the whole
movie kind of deal
it's just so much of it a CGI that it it
doesn't feel bad necessarily there are
moments where you're like huh but it
I've heard a couple people say it and I
I it truly Reigns I guess after watching
it uh is is that it just takes the
weight out of each and every scene they
they clearly like uh a couple different
times throughout the movie they'll put
like someone's head next to a rock like
while the while the Train's going by and
that's supposed to make you think of
like uh
all these different ones whatever uh
it just
there's clearly not a human being having
these things happen to them and you feel
that or do you feel the lack thereof
from that I guess and then also I did
it's hard to act next to Harrison Ford
and I would think he would bring you up
as a performer but also if you're trying
to be the next like Indiana Jones in a
way
you gotta have some Charisma and I I do
like Phoebe Waller Phoebe Waller Bridge
yeah Phoebe Waller Bridge as a uh uh as
an actress I think she's she's great in
most of the things that she does but
this performance was really wooden it
just felt like
going through the motions you should it
felt like Indie light uh instead of
making the character her own and and
doing that I don't know if that's James
mangold's direction or if that's from
higher ups like Kathleen Kennedy and
lucasfilm itself a little Bob Iger maybe
but
it it didn't Revitalize a single thing
for me while also still being a hell of
a lot more fun than I expected it to be
does that make sense yeah yeah well I
said I I enjoyed it I I am I I I was
told by a guy that I speak to that could
be a girl that um saw it at
um cans a few weeks ago they told me
um it's good it's not great as long as
you don't compare it to the originals
it's good much better than Crystal
School
much better than the Crystal Skull
um but um but don't just don't compare
it to the instant classic of Raiders of
the Lost Ark and you'll enjoy it
perfectly well and I did I thought it
was probably good I thought it liked it
through humor I would like some humor I
thought the storyline though made a lot
more sense I thought they they stepped
up to silly but then pull back which was
good which again I won't ruin it fast
and stormy but the other by the end of
it you'd think the the I think it's open
that there's some time travel involved
in this and I think that that's everyone
knows that now if you've now understood
or well yeah so there is a bit of time
travel
what what um Indiana Jones wants to do
would have been silly if he'd have done
it but you can completely understand why
he does but then the way they deal with
it I thought was actually quite good I
thought it was quite clever yeah
sorry is Jack Black in it yes he is all
the way through
yes
because it's the dial
that's amazing you'd like to say
something though Andrew because that's
when you say the important things I've
got to read it out yeah that's when you
get all the you get like an extra 200
300 characters with that kind of cash
yeah yeah yeah thank you so so much for
your contribution really helps the
channel
um
the CGI I thought was fine it was much
better than the Flash
there was no creepy babies
um
baby
it wasn't it wasn't in your face yeah
yeah a couple of times for the D aging
it's sort of like oh isn't it the
plastic scenery and there's one bit
where he's running across the top of the
train
and it's and it's actually quite bad CGI
it is oh that's that's not good I was
like that's either Harrison Ford like
actually acting it out like Robert De
Niro did an Irishman and them just not
being able to change the body or it's
just a actual CG model that cannot
physically move like a human truly does
very wooden wasn't it in like a like a
bloody like a wooden
[__] thingy yeah um but but yeah but
on the whole
um I just I'd have just enjoyed a bit
more humor
a little bit that would have done me
it would have been a good film but yeah
Indiana Jones discover the star game
why why Mr Perfect opportunity
we're talking about how to get it into
the real world let's yes do that the
Antiquity era actually opens up the
Stargate that's that's it's not actually
a time travel thing but the DHD that's
the new version of the DHD
the dial of Destiny but anyway how about
you guys what have you seen this week is
it anything that you enjoyed
yeah I'm watching The Walking Dead
still watching that
so there's this last week There's a two
shows I've been keeping up with one is
it's not a Sci-Fi show it's the bear
it's about this uh
the world's greatest Chef comes um comes
back to his home in Chicago to take over
a restaurant it's really really good
um but it is not sci-fi the other one
has that is sci-fi is the silo
it is just uh it's based on a series of
books and it is excellent it is just
really excellent Top Notch
um really top-notch storytelling um I
watched the um
the last episode last night episode 10
of season one and it was just like holy
[__] it was just really good closing
scene so I would I would definitely uh
recommend that
I I'm really enjoying it
is that the one where they're um trapped
underground yeah yes
Tim Robbins is is just he's such a mean
person
you know it's not Shawshank Redemption
let's just say that right and Andy
Dufresne
I think it's just really I think I
really think it's clever I like it when
a Sci-Fi on a show like this is based on
and not followed because you know it's
going to make sense in the end and I've
not I've actually I've read the first
novel years and years and years ago
um so I don't know where it's going past
like about the third episode or fourth
episode I think
um
but oh no it's just it's I'm just I'm
reassured and you have that nice fuzzy
Warm Glow that this is going to make
sense in the end because it's based on a
novel so um I like that but you know
it's just
it's a bit um
I don't know it's it's a bit slow in
places it's a slow burn which house
loves I prefer a bit more
stuff going on but it's so well acted
and so well written and they put so much
money into it
um you know Apple do quality over
quantity and you gotta love that and
then season two of foundation is out
very shortly can't wait for that when
does that come out
they're advertised at the moment so it
must be really soon
everything I watch everything
is it August it's August really is it
July I thought it's July or August so
maybe I mean I don't
know that makes sense in the next month
July then so that makes sense everything
I've watched on Apple now it's a
advert for that first so um uh I think
one of us just start watching up on it
but anyway
um the only other thing I've watched
today that I really enjoyed because
somebody on here told me I had to was um
into the spider-verse I watched the
first one today I loved it it was great
I didn't know I watched that last week A
lot of people are stressing that you
know like
um that if we got like an animated
Stargate movie because I was advocating
that you
um conclude SGU with an animated movie
before everyone else and maybe even lean
into how
um the Stargate gets revealed maybe
build that all into one but do an
animated movie and people will go and
you know go no animated sucks animation
sucks I watch something like into the
spider-verse so I'm like you do it like
that that would work and it would crap I
have it I enjoyed it
so
I can't wait for it to see it across the
spider verse now
if I could make a couple of book
recommendations
um project Hail Mary by Andrew and Andy
Weir the guy that wrote The Martian
excellent love that book oh my God
oh my God hey little Rocky this is I
need a rocky plushie is what I need
they're making it into a film and Ryan
Gosling is going to be the main guy I
can't wait to see how they oh no [__] oh
my God
Matt you did a video on that ages ago
and it still gets steady views yeah yeah
because it's a very good book it's
really good book
yeah the other one is uh finish up
consider
um fliebus
it's a culture novel it's um if you ever
wonder where Elon Musk gets all the
crazy names for his drone ships it's out
of this book series uh consider fliebus
is it is um it originally was like
one each chapter was a short story and
it's kind of cobbled together and
through the middle it's like the the
main character every single it's just
some imaginably bad thing happens to him
in chapter six chapter 7 some even more
incredibly bad thing happens to a child
and it just goes on and so I quit the
book and then um friends of mine guilted
me and no he gets better the other books
get better so just hang with it so I did
and it did actually get better the book
did and it was worth you know trudging
through the
the cult the the cannibal cult leader
and oh my God in heaven so but anyway
yeah I would I would suggest that the
thing I'm reading now is Triana Moore
space janitor
which is really funny it's real I mean
it's not I mean it's not like a kind of
a humor like Hitchhiker's Guide was but
it's really fun it's really engaging but
yeah it's about this
this uh space janitor
she's on a space station and she finds a
body well one of her robots finds a body
and then hijinks can ensue so I would
suggest Brianna more space elevator the
entire series is only a thousand pages
there's a lot of nepotism over there
have you noticed that in the safety
department yeah but uh oh no he's he's
borderline suicidal
um probably the next video he might
actually drink quite heavily in the next
video I've decided what I'm doing yet
but um
I might be doing a healthy safety Guy
video this week we'll see how I go
um but uh but yeah I was thinking like
about yeah a janitor Health SGC Janet
trying to keep the place tardy after
Okay God damn it I've just finished
cleaning up this place and it gets
[__] up yeah it gets invested by
replicators I have to collect clean up
all those blocks so
um but we'll see whatever jumps to mind
but um yeah guys thank you so so much
for the chat we've um had one of the
world's rights once more
um storming it is so nice to see you
back thank you so much I appreciate it
thank you thank you for the warm welcome
back I feel like the Grinch my heart has
just grown an extra size three times too
much
[Music]
uh Matthew thank you so so much and
Harris as always you've been marvelous
um
yeah we've been sidetracked so what else
can you understand thank you so much
everybody in the audience especially and
you guys that um contribute to the
channel today that you've been marvelous
say goodbye everybody bye everybody see
y'all toodles
foreign